let's say return to the story about you
keep being investigated by the European
Parliament for Miss spending its funds
William Dartmouth or you could bear me p
and a member of the allowance for direct
democracy in Europe joins me now from
Brussels a very good evening to you and
good evening good evening good evening
and issue another some point out the
Conservatives for instance are being
investigated for overspending during the
2015 election do you feel then that the
European Parliament is indulging in
something of a witch hunt well I would
point out the Conservatives are being
investigated by the Electoral Commission
and also the police and this is very
very different but melody is correct and
I'm very great to have the opportunity
to come on your program because I want
to correct what's been said so far which
is entirely misleading and indeed untrue
you Kip never received any money you Kip
never spent any money and you Kip has
never miss spent any money the money is
entirely money that was spent by a
pan-european political party called the
Alliance for direct democracy in Europe
or which you keep us apart there are
politicians from 11 countries in there
only one of them is only one of them is
the UK so your headline and your news
band your breaking news and what are the
all are many enemies in the media
writing up the correct headline should
have been pan-european political party
in the pan European political party a
DDD's expenditure is not entirely agreed
by internal auditors acting for the
European Parliament and that's all it is
that's all it is she's like a saint not
worth needing certainly not sort
certainly not worth leaving a 77 p.m.
bulletin with but all right and if you
have it in for us but I think you do
when you would accept that you keep make
up roughly half of the membership of the
adde its 383 meg was nominated to you
keepin it no there was new kid that
spent the money in the in the UK no you
can never spent the money but you can
never spend money the registered that
the Alliance for the direct democracy in
Europe which is a registered
pan-european political party which had
to go through a registration process in
order to be to be accepted and
recognized
is they were the people that spent the
money you can never spent the money is
just completely those of you who there
and by the by the way money in the UK
what what party would they members of
the people who spent the money in the UK
I just just just clear it up for us
there's they were they were the Alliance
that they were the Alliance for director
option in Europe or they were all they
were people or they were pollsters and
distinguished media people like yourself
who thee who were you know instructed by
the eight by the ad de I mean I missed
it I don't want to be I don't want to be
a new with you a bit of it what and
nothing therefore to do with you kit I
don't know nothing directly indirectly
indirectly and as I pointed out earlier
the the Alliance of direct democracy in
Europe is a registered political party
composed of politicians from 11
different european countries of which
the UK is one right and so it's clear
we're just just just for the British
audience because I don't think anyone in
the UK is actually heard of this
alliance for democracy in whatever it is
in well you're so so you are they
standing in the general election you
ought you ought to cover that you ought
to cover the EU a little bit more than
perhaps actually because it's rather
important we think it's too important in
British political life but if you
covered it a little bit more that you
you would you would be aware that that
that that that all the political parties
represented in the European Parliament
including the conservatives including
the Labour Party of which mr. Kinnick
was is not a very distinguished member
or by the way including including the
liberal liberal democrats are all are
all part of pan-european political
parties which make them which make them
eligible for for funding for for for for
for political purposes and in this
particular case the Internal Auditors
acting for the European Parliament but
their internal not external disagree
with some of the expenditure now as
nigel has pointed out is that of course
the President of the European Parliament
assaults is not exactly on our side in
fact he's doing everything he can to
frustrate brexit and the brexit case and
so therefore he's leak this to to to Sky
News and as somebody who
who's elected MEP I've never seen this
report I can't get hold of it I've tried
to today we'll hear more about that on
Monday let me just lastly put your [ __ ]
to you the overall point though about
you Kip's attitude to taking money from
the european parliament in terms of your
salaries your generous allowances your
pensions your severance payments and
whatever Nigel Farage I said hasn't he
and we all know this you could use the
money and wherewithal provided by the EU
to fight against britain's membership of
the EU there is an argument given that
this is taxpayers money for you now to
to pack up and leave now that we have
leftover about to leave the EU no but I
tell you I know for two reasons first of
all I wonder why you and your colleagues
never make this point to scottish
nationalists to the scottish notches
there's 50 for scottish nationalists mps
at westminster who have exactly the same
point of view lost their line for red
room if you didn't notice unfortunately
well they're still there still plugging
the same line and they lost their
referendum we won us and unfortunately
and very unfortunately until the moment
that we leave everybody in the UK
including the people i have the honor to
represent i I is our fully bound by all
the EU rules laws and regulations and
it's important it's incumbent on us to
stand up for our constituents and do our
best so long as that pertains when we
leave the you when when we leave the EU
and I wish it was sooner rather than
later of course we leave that's when we
leave and when you take your severance
payment what sorry will you take a
13-hour thousand i hope it's like i'll
have to think about that won't i but i
don't see why the proposition should be
there's alright for Stephen King up who
you gave airtime on your program 222222
or get the EU pension it's all right for
Scottish nash's and Welsh nationalist
and shin fain to get pensions but it's
not ok 44 actually you keep em eps so i
think it's a frankly a bizarre point of
view to put forward it's a very very
feeble debating point and frankly not
worthy of somebody of your very
considerable intellect for whom I have
tremendous admiration by the way well a
tremendous admiration view thank you
very much steel or Dartmouth for coming
to clear it all up thank you I've tried
I've tried